ciao a tutti io mi chiamo cesare e oggi
vi parlerò di come uscire la tua confort
non vedete al giorno d'oggi ci sono un
sacco di ragazzi che sono molto
intelligenti prendono voti altissimi a
scuola sono brillanti hanno un futuro
stellare però poi quando li guardo
veramente perché non hanno una passione
non hanno qualcosa ecco sono veramente
appassionati non hanno una missione
nella vita e oggi parlerà proprio di
questo di come sistemarlo vedete voi
potrete pensare che questo problema sia
solamente dei bambini ma io penso che se
anche degli adulti che amano i soldi ma
non amano quello che su quello che
lavorano il loro lavoro
vedremo insieme come la mia esperienza e
la mia passione mi abbia portato ne
abbia viene abbiamo dato gli strumenti
per risolvere questo problema
ok la scuola insegna un sacco di cose
insegna la matematica insegna l'italiano
insegna la geografia sono cose ottime
sono fantastiche ti rendono colto la
cultura importante e dobbiamo essere
molto orgoglioso della cultura
dell'italia però non ti insegna una cosa
non ti insegna come vivere una vita
felice e piena non ti insegna a vivere
esperienze e ad evitare persone vivendo
una passione e questo credo che sia
molto importante alla base della vita
facciamo qualche passo indietro
ero in terza superiore liceo scientifico
scienze applicate a milano ed era un
ragazzo molto insicuro e molto timido
non aveva molti amici
ero prendevo brutti voti
un giorno però tutto è cambiato grazie
mio professore in informatica
ho imparato programmare e la mia vita è
cambiata per sempre
ho iniziato a partecipare a conferenze
eventi workshop per costruire up e
creare app e fare siti web è stato
fantastico aveva qualcosa su cui potevo
lavorare nel mio tempo libero poi scopro
il davide hub di sì
una conferenza per giovani sviluppatori
di app scopro che il ticket è molto
costoso e partecipare è molto difficile
perché apple a far la selezione molto
accurata molto selettivo però è molto
ammirabile da parte di apple che mette a
disposizione 300 ticket per studenti
sviluppatori di app in tutto il mondo e
quindi ho deciso di candidarmi e di
prendere al volo dell'iniziativa quindi
mi sono candidato per due settimane
costruito questa app in cui mi sono
concentrato molto sulle interazioni che
all'utente con l'app poteva riconoscere
il sorriso poteva vedere e riconoscere
lo sguardo gli occhi poteva fare un
sacco di cose potuto devi chiedere in
fare una domanda e ti poteva rispondere
in modo offline e su qualsiasi domanda
abbastanza incredibile
ero molto nervoso quando ho saputo che è
stato accettato
però quando ho viaggiato da sola san
francisco sono veramente ha veramente
capito che è stata un'esperienza
fantastica di cui sono molto
riconoscente è stata la più bella
esperienza della mia vita ho conosciuto
persone veramente in gamba
i giovani talenti in cui amavo parlare e
discutere di idee
ovviamente sono tornato a casa e molto
molto motivato e entusiasta volevo
condividere con tutti quest'esperienza
cambia rendevo conto che
i miei compagni non avevano le stesse
opportunità quindi ho pensato come po
come può uno studente con quel ragazzo
vive le mie stesse esperienze
entusiasmanti allora pensata una domanda
cosa ti piace fare nel tempo libero può
essere qualsiasi cosa può essere giocare
ai videogiochi
oppure può essere vediamo dipingere
queste sono cose molto divertenti da
fare se vi piacciono farle oppure la
montagna campeggio sciare bellissimo se
ci pensate bene sono tutte cose che si
possono fare per per hobby ma anche per
lavoro passione e coraggio programmare
mi ha insegnato che una volta che trovi
qualcosa che ti piace fare diventi
superman diventi coraggioso siamo un po
come l'inclusione una scatola è molto
bello stare una scatola caldo sapete
siamo nella nostra cosa scatola come se
fosse la nostra confort son nostra zona
di confort dove noi amiamo spendere il
tempo però credo che tutte le cose belle
se non fuori da questa scatola
certo è difficile uscire da questo box
questo contenitore bisogna evitare le
viti bisogna essere coraggiosi essere
forti però una volta che sei uscito
trovi i raggi del sole etero che sia
fantastico
dopo questa esperienza da david avidi sì
volevo e roero che le idee e volevo
creare qualcosa fuori da scuola carico a
cosa qualche app
l'ho fatto fuori la scuola ha
partecipato a quattro in tutto il mondo
canada stati uniti germania svizzera e
questo sono gli acton sono competizioni
di programmazione in cui i giovani
studenti di scuole superiori università
si riuniscono per creare qualcosa una
prostitua in sole 36 ore
quindi si fa gruppi di tre quattro
persone
e insieme si lavora su un unico progetto
giorno e notte
vedete è così entusiasmante fare
qualcosa che piace usare la propria
passione e che ci si dimentica quasi
della realtà che ci circonda e siamo
così immersi in quello che ci piace fare
che ci dimentichiamo che stiamo facendo
quasi un lavoro quindi qua ero
all'università di pennsylvania
philadelphia e con altri giovani ragazzi
abbiamo creato un'app che aiuta i
bambini a curare il diabete
ero soddisfattissimo del risultato i
bambini possano quest'app incoraggio i
bambini a misurare il livello di
glucosio nel sangue e abbiamo costruito
un interfaccia grafica divertente
piacevole con tante animazioni quello
che piace quello che piace ai bambini in
effetti abbiamo 16 siamo suddivisi nei
ruoli c'è chi voleva fare il designer
che voleva fare
l'esperto di user experience oppure chi
voleva fare lo sviluppatore io abbiamo
creato questo prodotto oppure a new york
dove abbiamo dove con altri quattro
liceali demo creato un'app che fornisce
che dà la possibilità ai bambini di
vedere musica di godere di musica e
video sicuri senza parolacce senza
contenuti espliciti è così bello aiutare
le persone poi quello che ci faccia fare
questo senso di pienezza e di felicità
l'app di cui sono molto orgoglioso è
vita vita insegna ai bambini alla
matematica e lo fa in modo abbastanza
interessante i bambini possono disegnare
la loro risposta sullo schermo per
rispondere alle domande aritmetiche i
bambini possono fare i conti su un
blocco note possono impostare nella
difficoltà le operazioni con la quale
vogliono esercitarsi vita entra in top
100 in 19 paesi
ma quello che conta veramente è aiutare
le persone con la propria passione non
sono i risultati non sono i premi e
usare quello che piace fare per aiutare
gli altri
comunque
ho parlato un sacco con tante persone
ottimi amici coetanei hanno tutte idee
di applicazioni fantastiche stupende
ci sono un sacco di idee nella testa
degli italiani sono così creativi siamo
così creativi noi italiani per quello
che ho notato è che non tutti mettono in
pratica le loro idee non tutti tutti
rimandano al domani quello che possono
fare oggi e questo è un peccato perché
comunque è in questo momento che stiamo
vivendo una rivoluzione tecnologica non
accadrà tra vent'anni è questo momento
la sto muovendo proprio ora quindi
riassumendo quello che io ho trovato
come consigli per uscire dalla comfort
zone sono quattro step trova la passione
creare qualcosa fuori da scuola
possibilmente perché solo lì capisci che
stai facendo qualcosa che ti piace
veramente fare non sei forzato dai
genitori e dagli insegnanti
oppure e poi aiutare le persone credo
che sia fantastico di dare quel qualcosa
le persone con qualcosa che piace fare
e in più farlo adesso ho scoperto che
fare qualcosa adesso se la chiave di non
rimandare ma che al giorno d'oggi
noi vediamo l'acqua televisione abbiamo
un sacco di passatempi come per esempio
guardare se la nostra serie televisiva
preferita oppure andare in discoteca
sono cose fantastiche da fare bellissime
divertenti per ora un po troppo che ci
disse che ci distraggono dalla nostra
dalla nostra passione al nostro focus
della sulla vita credo che ci facciano
perdere un po di tempo però credo che
sia cosa divertenti da fare
poi sempre prendo un po il focus di
quello che veramente conta lo faccio poi
una domanda qual è la vostra missione
nella vita
grazie